okay uh welcome everyone to the ddps
seminar
uh before we introduce our invited
speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk
unless you have questions if you do have
questions you are welcome to unmute and
ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in
q a session at the end
second today's gdpr seminar is open
to the external audiences therefore
no classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded
in our youtube channel that's about it
now let me introduce our speaker today
okay it is an honor to host yan jung
shin
uh who is a pregnant assistant professor
at the division of
applied mathematics brown university
um it's well known that it's a home of
the physics informed neural network
which is the the most popular uh the
machine learning based
physics solver these days he completed
his ph phd in mathematics at the ohio
university
ohio state university in 2018 advised by
professor dongbin his research
interests lie in mathematics of machine
learning
scientific computing approximation
theory
and uncertainty quantification today yan
zhang
will talk about mathematical
understanding of
modern machine learning in theory
algorithms and applications which is
very interesting topic
so please enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk
now without further due let me pass the
button
to yanzhang by asking one random
questions as usual today's random
question is
what is your favorite things to do other
than research
oh i have to i have one
peculiar thing to do watching youtube
videos
uh twice faster than normal speed okay
to save your time yes
and watch many watch as many as
materials so quickly
oh wow there is a skill okay
it's all yours yeah thank you so much
for the invitation
uh today i'm going to talk about some of
my works on
machine learning um
machine learning based ai technologies
have revolutionized both industry and
academia is not a
big surprise to nowadays to see a news
article
that ai techniques can do wonder
it has achieved a tremendous success on
many challenging applications
here i listed some of the famous
examples
starting from alphago alpha fold
and some image generations and
even ai composes classical music
and more recently these machine learning
techniques have been applied to solve
scientific problems so this is the
uh one line i borrowed from goe document
the scientific machine learning
is a core component of ai and
computation technology
that can be trained with the scientific
data to automate the human skills
and many companies also have huge
interest
in this field so here i showed a couple
of examples
nvidia they use machine learning model
what they called
simnet to develop the next generation
gpu
and their core technique is called
physics informed neural network which i
will
introduce in a moment and also siemens
also interested in using it
in their digital tool digital twin
models and also
ansys is also employed those
techniques machine learning is very
powerful as demonstrated some people
even call it as a magical black box and
put whatever data they have
into machine learning algorithms and
expect to get some great research
however this is not true much of this
success
involves lots of trial and error and
many tricks and at the moment
uh it's safe to say that we lack basic
mathematical understanding of machine
learning
when when and why it works this is very
important as machine learning is getting
applied to make
life critical decisions such as
autonomous vehicle
the general goals as an on applied and
computational mathematician is to
provide
mathematical guarantees and based on
that
to develop fast robust and reliable
numerical methods and algorithms for
machine learning then why deem learning
so successful
so what i view is there are four
components that leads this tremendous
success one is the modeling which is a
neural network
and techniques that can train those
model which is typically done by
gradient
based optimization and along with the
big data
and powerful computing power then
combining all these together
we achieved some great success and as a
mathematician the personally
more interested in these two perspective
neural network and
gradient based optimization so this is a
typically the
one is different different in scientific
machine learning
uh what has been changed is the our data
now becomes scientific data
and on the top of this we have laws of
physics physical laws are the
conclusions based on long ear scientific
observations and
experiments so the goal is we want to
incorporate those laws of physics into
the neural network
and physics informed neural network is
one of them to
trying to do that
the rest of this talk will be themed by
the data-driven approximation
so the goal is to approximate a
non-target function f
star which can be solution to the pde
or if you are interested in some image
classification or
then f star can be image classifier
and what is known to us is the data or
some prior knowledge
so what i mean by data is an input
output pair x
i is an input and y i is its
corresponding output
some domain knowledge could be some pdes
and to achieve this goal
we typically need to choose the two
things one is the parameterized modal
clauses
so in this talk i'll be focusing on
neural network but classically
we were a numerical analyst were
using uh polynomials or wavelets
and once the parameterized model classes
were chosen
the next thing is to decide
approximation schemes
approximation schemes can be decomposed
into the two step
the first step is the formulation of the
loss
and the second step is to minimize the
then this actually creates the multiple
fundamental questions
that which i will illustrate in this
slide
suppose f star is our target function we
wish
to approximate and to do this we choose
a model class and in this talk this
model class will be neural network
then let's say h hat is the best model
belongs to this model class to
approximate this f
stop then study of these two difference
and this error is called approximation
error and study of this error belongs to
the classical approximation theory
in this era data doesn't play any role
so this error is completely determined
by
our target function and your choice of
the model class
so there's no data placing a role in
this era
and now data comes in we define a loss
function
then let's say h m is our minimizer of
the loss function
here small m is denoted by the number of
the data
then the difference between this
minimizer and the best function
is called estimation error this error
comes from the
finiteness of our data so if we were to
have
infinitely many number of data then this
error will be zero
then combining these two errors together
we call it generalization error
so in some sense the understanding
generalization error is the relevant of
some theoretical work
but what we see in practice after uh
training of the gradient descent
algorithm what we get
is h tilde so this is the outcome of our
algorithm
then the difference between these two is
called optimization error
so in this talk i will going to talk
about the both
the first part i will talk about the
generalization era
in terms of the physics informed the
neural network and the second part i
will focus in optimization
especially mathematical analysis of some
machine learning phenomena in trained
neural net the photo phenomena and the
dying ray loop
since all of those topic involved in
neural network so let me first
just go over one is neural network
so starting with an input x lies in d
dimensional space
we apply on our fine map to get z1
here w1 is a matrix b1 is a
vector and w1 is called a weight matrix
and b1 is called bias vector
and then we apply a nonlinear map v and
then again
another alpha map to get z2 and then we
repeat this procedure
until we get zl then
the mapping from x to zl is called
a layer neural network
and the collection of those
weight matrixes and device vector is
called the network
parameters and this is something we need
to learn
and the network architecture is just a
collection of the size of the weight
matrixes
so for example w1 is the matrix of
size n by d and intermediate layer
is the m by n and the last layer is a 1
by
n here i assume the output is just a
real valued function
and typically l is called the depth of
the network
small n is the width of the network and
v is called
activation function some popular choices
the hyperbolic time h
and uh real function which is just a max
function
then with that let me talk about the
convergence theory of physics informed
neural network
physics-informed neural network is a dim
learning framework for solving pde
uh this was first appeared on the
archive in november
2017 and merely within three years and
eight months he's already cited more
than 1600 times
and pin also has appears on media
multiple times
but here i show the first time i
saw pin in the media so nvidia ceo
jensen huang
addressing ai for science in the super
computing seminar in 19
and he's mentioning pin the principle is
the same as before
trying to embed the physics equation
into the neural network and one way of
doing it is the
pin the setup for the pin is goes follow
so i will focus on the fourth
problem although uh pin can be applied
for both way
but for theoretical analysis i was
focusing on the fourth problem
so we consider the following pde here l
is the differential
operator and b is a boundary operator
and f
and g are pd data and u and g and
u and boundary of u is just a standard
the open and bounded then the goal is to
find the neural network
that approximate the pde solution and
what are known to us
is the two things one is the pointwise
pde data
some data from the interior and the data
from
boundary and if you completely know
about f
and g then this you may think of this is
not a data
or something you can get freely but if
you don't know
f and g then you can treat this as a
data
and on the top of that we might know we
know the physics equation
in terms of l and the b
so as i said the goal is to encode the
physics equations
and the data into the neural network
then how we do this
for the pin the original work proposed
to
do this job by minimizing the loss
function
then prototype pin loss function is
defined in the following manner
composed with the two terms one is the
mean square loss
of the interior part both physics and
the data
and the other term is the mean square
arrow of the boundary
physics and the data the method is to
minimize this
pin loss function and we get the
minimizer
which is the network parameter and by
using this
minimize the parameter back to neural
network we get a physics thing from the
neural network
the white pins there are multiple pros
and cons for the pins but one
one part is easy and simple to implement
it
and someone someone says someone also
saying as a joke
the high school student can solve the
schredinger equation using pin
after spending a couple of hours
and the second one is the is a one of
the
methods that sold the pde without meshes
and also great potential in solving
inverse problem
especially and also take advantage of
the rapid development
of deep learning yet
it lacks theoretical understanding and
also it has some
potential issues in optimization
procedure
but at the moment for the first part i
will focus on
just the theoretical analysis assuming
minimizer
is achieved and one natural question one
might ask is the consistent
consistency uh result meaning that
here m denotes the number of the data
point
then for fixed number of the data point
we get a
neural network physics informed neural
network then the natural question
a natural question would be as the
number of the data point
increase we get a sequence of the
physics informed neural network
then the question is will this sequence
of physics
inform the neural networks converges to
the solution to the pde
if it is then we say it is consistent
for the analysis we propose so-called
helder regularized pin loss it is the
regularized pin loss
in particular use of the held constant
of the l
of the neural network and v of the
neural network
so we are going to focus on the
following problem minimize
the helder regularized pin loss and
zeta star is our
optimum parameters then we get a neural
network
and as the number of data increase we
get a sequence of the neural network
the question i want to address today is
the whether
this sequence will converge to the pd
solution or not
if it is in what no and the answer is
yes and the no means the uniform
and let me briefly talk about what is
the motivation of using helder
regularized
laws ideally what we want to minimize
is the expected pin loss meaning just
we want to minimize the l of
h minus f in continuous null and b
of h minus g in continuous node that is
corresponding to this expected pin loss
however we cannot achieve this we cannot
access to this expected pin loss so that
we somehow sort of like minimizing
empirical loss
but one theorem we prove is the
following
uh by assuming our samples are iid
then with high probability expected pin
loss can be bounded by helder
regularized pin loss
and this other term actually goes to
zero as the
number of the data increase and this pre
uh this pre uh suggests
one way of controlling expected pin loss
in a nice manner
and in this upper bound actually we did
not apply any optimization procedure
yet so this is purely obtained by
applying probabilistic space filling
argument
so by applying the optimization by
reducing this well the regularized loss
is sufficiently
decay fast that we can expect to get
some convergence
so in order to guarantee the convergence
we need to
uh impose some proper conditions on the
neural network class because what we get
is this hm which is minimizer
and in order for the convergence we need
to
uh sort of like guarantee that this
generalization error goes to zero
which means that approximation error has
to goes to zero
which means that neural network class
should be sufficiently large
enough to capture this target function
at the same time
we need to a way to control this
estimation error
so that we can reduce the convergence we
can uh
derive the convergence and from now on
for the ease of the notation i will use
this functional notation because the
neural network is determined by the
network parameter
meaning that we can choose a function in
the neural network
class so we're going to use this
functional location
then there are two key assumptions on
the for the convergence
one is interpolation of the data
there exists a function the neural
network that
interpolates the the data which means
that achieve the zero pin loss
the prototype chain loss this assumption
controls the approximation error
and the second assumption is the uniform
boundedness of the held constant
and this controls the estimation error
and these two assumptions are essential
for the proof although the assumption
one can be relaxed
a bit yet these two assumptions can be
both satisfied if there exists a neural
network
that is exactly the solution to the pde
then with these two critical assumptions
now we can have some
convergence reject suppose the
assumption one and two hold
and let's say hm is the minimizer of the
helder regularized loss
and with high probability expected pin
loss
evaluated at our minimizer actually
converges to zero
with the following rates so this is the
worst
case rate of conversions furthermore
l of the physics inform the neural
network b of the physics of informed
neural network converges to the pde data
uniformly so this is a great result
in the sense that we guess we can
guarantee some sort of like convergence
after applying the operators however
this uniform conversion is not strong
enough to conclude the consolation
convergence to the pde so one example is
this so that all the derivative
converges to
zero uniformly but function itself does
not
so this is the moment we need to specify
what kind of the class of the pde
we are looking for so in that we
actually borrow the shelter theory from
pde
and combine it with the maximum weak
maximum principle
the shelter theory guarantees the the
pointwise evaluation
and sufficient regularity and the
uniqueness of the solution
and weak maximum principle controls the
how we
deviate from the boundary because unlike
other pde method
pin does not enforce the boundary
condition to be satisfied in the first
place
so there must be a some uh technical
tool that controls the
boundary values in in some
nice manner and that is the weak maximum
principle
by combining all this we can now have a
nice convergence theorem
suppose the assumptions hold uh conclude
uh involving the child assumption and
weak maximum principle
and the two assumptions that i mentioned
earlier
and hm is the felder minimi uh minimizer
of the helder regularized loss
then with probability 1 over iid sample
sequence of the physics informed neural
network converges to the solution to the
pde
uniformly and furthermore if the neural
network satisfies the boundary
conditions
exactly then the convergence mode
becomes h1
and here's some proof idea but let me
skip it but similar result hold for
parabolic case
here i show some demonstration so the
purpose of this plot is to just
illustrate the convergence of pin to the
pd solution
just what i just showed you before
so here i consider the special case
where uh held the exponent
is one which becomes the latest
regularization
which is shown by red and the standard
prototype pin loss
result is shown by blue curve
and here dashed line is the rate of
convergence from
our theory then you can see that
theoretical result is well observed by
the numerical simulation as well
and but what what is interesting is
actually the
without any regularization just a
standard physics informed the neural
network
seems to converge exponentially fast and
saturate
afterwards which is something we cannot
guarantee from the theory the red one is
guaranteed by the theory
and similar results for the heat to
equation
the upper dashed line is our theoretical
line
and the red one is our numerical
simulation and the blue one
is the standard physics informed neural
network
now let me move on to my second topic
which is the
optimization error
so mainly i will going to discuss the
two things one is the
flutter phenomena and the dyn ray loop
for the optimization the setup is the
following
the goal is to approximate an unknown
target function
f star and our data is just
x i and y i data set and
model class is the neural network and
approximation scheme is the neural
network training which i will going to
discuss a little bit more
so training refers to a procedure of
finding
appropriate network parameters that
minimize the loss function
here i assume the mean squared loss
and typically this loss is minimized by
gradient descent like method and
typically gradient descent like method
involves with the two stats step one
is the random initialization of the
parameter
and step two is repetitive application
of some iterative schemes
until converge however this is difficult
to solve
because it is not not convex and also
non-linear
at the same time this is the part where
many intriguing phenomena
are observed and
those are paletto phenomena and the
dying ray loop
let me first illustrate uh what is the
philatel phenomena
so here you could we consider a simple
learning task just trying to approximate
a sine function
using two layer rail network of with
hundred
and we train it with using just a
standard gradient descent using full
batch
and learning rate is 10 to the minus
three
and this figure shows the training loss
versus the number of iteration
and we see that the loads decrease fast
to get fast
in the early phase and then quickly
saturate
and some may even think that training is
done
and may terminate the training at this
point
however if we continue gradient descent
what we see is here the loss suddenly
decreased fast again
before saturating at around 10 million
iteration
and if we go further we see that
similar behavior repeated this is
so-called
phlegm phenomena then white flat
phenomena is a problem well as you can
see
it made us too difficult to decide when
to terminate the procedure
and furthermore it makes the training
very slow so therefore
the goal for us is to understand what
are the root causes of this phenomena
and once we identify the root causes
then can we avoid it
and make a fast convergence i mean fast
some training method
and that was our motivation but
to address this question we need to
understand some basic
understanding of gradient descent
training dynamics
will it converge if it is then will it
find a good solution or not
so i will going to go over all these
questions in sql
here is the setup we consider the
simplest setup we can
think of but not too trivial is the
univariate
relu network here which is written in
the following manner
and you may notice that we don't have
the w here because the
v is the rayleigh so that it is the
homogeneous
positive homogeneous so that without
loss of generality you can do this
and the one simplest example is that
when
small n equal to one and the c
equal to c one equal to one then this is
just the max function
a little bit uh not located at b one
then this is our one realization of this
neural network
for the training we consider the square
loss function
and consider the gradient the flow
dynamics so from now on we are going to
assume that this theta
is the function of time t governed by
this dynamics and
this is our primer interest of the
parameter and want to know that how this
function
behave as the training goes on
for this analysis one of the there are
two
key concepts for understanding of this
analysis
one is activation patterns the other is
microscope data i will illustrate what
are those
in this exam in the following
illustration
suppose we have five neurons which is
shown as the red dots
and we have a 10 training data point
which is the
purple cross marks then with respect to
each neurons
we can define a partition of the
training data
so those four point left four point
belongs to this u0 set
and the middle two purple dots belongs
to u1 set
and u2 set is the empty etc
then what we mean by activation pattern
is the
size of each u-set so in this example
u0 small u0 is the cardinality of the
capital u-0 set so that which is the
full
and u1 is 2 etc and collection of all
these numbers
is what we called activation patterns
and macroscopic data is its
corresponding average
data so by average of this full point
is the microscopic data corresponding to
the u0 set
and same thing for the u1 goes on
so these two are the most important
concept in understanding
phenomena and the training method that
we're going to explain in later
then with that uh i'm going to show our
main
first main result before that here is
some notation
here we consider the loss factor for
each of the component
is the discreteancy between our neural
network and the output data
evaluated at the case data point
so naturally the norm of this loss
vector becomes the
our original the target loss function
the one main result is the following for
time
interval on which the activation
patterns do not
change there exists a linear subspace
such that the loss does not decay at all
in its complement space but it decays
exponentially fast
on this corresponding v space so meaning
that
for the time being where activation
patterns do not change
we get a fast conversions on this
subspace
and the rest of them are just the
remainder of this part
so this flatter is convergence to
the orthogonal complement of the loss
vector so in other words
a factor corresponds to a period of time
during which the activation patterns do
not change
so that is the root cause of because of
why plato phenomena occurs
and next we provide some quantitative
result of the gradient flow
mainly will gradient flow converge or
and the will gradient flow find a good
solution or not
so again theta t follows these following
gradient flow dynamics
and the one partial theorem the partial
convergence theorem we prove is the
following
suppose that there exists a time
interval the t from infinity
where activation patterns do not change
then
theta t converges to a stationary point
then this provides a partial convergence
result
the next question is then what is the
stationary point
and how it looks like so we quantified
the if and only if condition for a point
being a stationary
but i want to emphasize just one thing
on this level
so this condition shows that fully
trained network
interpolates microscopic data
i will going to explain this theorem and
lemma in the next
uh slide here suppose we are trying to
fit the five data points shown in here
one two three four five is a double
shape and we train with the
relu network of with eight just gd and
constant running rate etc
and you can see that fully trained
network interpolate all the microscopic
data which is
shown as the red dots here and here
furthermore here we show the training
trajectories
of the biases and the coefficient with
respect to the number of
iterations and here black dashed line
corresponds to five data points
and what we can see here is at around
the 10 to the five iteration
you can see that all the biases are
somehow stabilized
which meaning that we have fixed
activation pattern
afterwards meaning that
after ten to the five iteration for the
rest we have the fixed activation
pattern
so that we should expect to have
conversions
based on our theorem and this is what's
happening as you can see in the
coefficient
once the biases are stabilized now
coefficients become converged
and we have reached the convergence
and also one thing is related to the
later dying ray loop you can see that
these two upper two does not change at
all during the training
and this is because of the dying rail
which i will going to explain in the
last topic
all right then now we know that will
gradient flow converge
or not and how it looks like and the
final result
is of this will
greg and the flow provide a good
solution or not and here is what we
prove
a fully trained network continuously
connect
consecutive least squares line
so let me explain what it means in this
flaw
so suppose we have these neurons shown
as the
green dots and cross marks are our
training data
then we focus on just the uj set which
is the
interval that corresponding to
interlaced of the
consecutive neurons then by focusing
only this
realm we can just fit a list of square
line
by using those five data points
and same thing can be done for other
realm
and its microscopic data
is the red dot so the list of sql line
actually
uh passes through this macroscopic data
and what fully trained neural network do
is continuously connect this list to
square line
what the flow and gradient decent
training do
and at this moment no further month is
possible by gradient descent
all right then all these theoretical
results
we gained provides some insightful
result so one is the plateau is the
period
during which the activation patterns do
not change
and the second observation is that once
biases are fixed the optimal
coefficients
can be obtained by solving the least
squares problem
and this combine these two we propose a
new training method
which is we call active neuron list
squares
the idea is that we want to generate
candidate bias vectors that have
different activation patterns
and then we solve the list square and
choose the one with the smallest loss
value
and here let me quickly recall you what
was the activation pattern
so given the five data five neurons here
and each neuron actually uh partition
the data and the collection of these
the size of each use set constitute the
what we mean by activation pattern
then actually we can manually uh change
the activation pattern for example
if we move the first neuron to the left
then this creates the new activation
pattern
so you can see that uh here is a
number of the data point of u0 cent was
full but by moving the first
neuron to the left oops we get the
users that becomes three new ones that
becomes three
and do the same thing if we move the
first neutron to the right
then we got u zero step five and u1 set
one
so in this manner we can create
a multiple candidate vectors that
generates a different activation pattern
so this is the one example another
example
etc then among all these different
candidate bias
we get a different activations and we
choose the one with the smallest loss
value
and we have efficient very efficient
procedure of choosing the best one
but let me skip that one and show the
performance so this is the 1d function
approximation task
so this is a target function it's a
discontinuous left one is the low
frequency
the right one uh right one is
somehow high frequency here and here is
the training loss versus the number of
iteration
and uh we compared with the gradient
descent adam
and so-called lsd ls adam so
applying list to square and the gradient
descent adam
uh iteratively and the black solid line
is the justice
standard deleted square at the right
after the initialization
and the blue one is the uh training
reserved by
active neutral list square you can see
that with the merely hundred iteration
it already achieved the best
training loss and compared and also in
terms of the cpu time
also is the shortest time and get the
smallest loss
and what about the generalization error
so here i show the prediction error here
and you can see that and electronically
square achieved the best result among
others
one particular thing is the following if
you see the green dashed line
and our blue line you see the training
error
is roughly the same however when you see
the prediction error
active neutral needs to square actually
generate the
pro produce the more a great result on
the generalization performance so
activity analysis period also
generalizes well
and we also extended this method to the
multiple dimensional task
so this is the one example for the 2d
function approximation
the target function is so-called the
booking function which is a quite uh
difficult function to be approximated
because if you see the
values of the function it goes up to 0
to 200
and also you see that there is a shock
belly
in in here where the somehow
non-differentiable
part has appeared and here is to show
the training loss versus the number of
the
iterations you can see that activation
square is uh
perform roughly four orders of the
magnitude
better than any other any of the other
method
and this is also cpu time and also not
to mention about the generalization
error
achieve the smallest generalization
error and the smallest
training loss and this can be
immediately applied to solve the pin
so one of the bottleneck of the pin
uh some my people call is the it's hard
to optimize
or there are multiple some issues but
without changing any activation function
or without changing any neural network
architecture
we just use the two-layer neural network
and trained with active neural listeners
here
we can solve this wave equation nicely
and here i show the training result and
the relative l2 error
relative electro error is shown as the
dashed line and you can see that
active neural needs query is the only
method that works
then none of them are working really
well but
achieve the 10 to the minus 6 training
loss and relative error is roughly 10 to
the -3 level
and here is the absolute value error
plot
on the domain for the wave equation
so that was the plateau phenomena
and the last one is the dying ray loop
so let me illustrate what is the diagram
so
suppose we want to approximate the
absolute value of
x which is simple function
but someone said the deemed neural
network is a very powerful
so suppose you want to use the 10 layer
rail
network of with two theoretically
this neural network is powerful enough
to exactly
represent this absolute value of x
because of the following relation so
absolute value of x is just an
addition of the two neuron identity map
is also addition of the two neuron
so that you can just decompose absolute
value of x and just identity map
recursively so target function can be
exactly represented by a neural network
but when you actually train it
then what you get is nine out of the ten
times you see that this flat dashed line
so this is the trained result and this
the blue line blue solid line is our
target function
so you can see that clearly there is a
huge gap
between theory and practice
and in terms of this the diagram that i
showed you earlier there is no
approximation error because can be
exactly represented by this the
10 layer with two reload network for the
target function
so there is no approximation error and
also there is
no or negligible estimation error
because
we trained it over 3000 training data or
more
for only just approximating this simple
1d function
so generalization error is negligible or
none so this is mainly because of the
optimization error
and what's happening here
so dyn relu is our uh
reason why it is happening so that
really in simple words
neuron becomes a constant function so
this is the
one some illustrating example suppose
you have two relu neurons
going this word and network and if your
data point
lies between this then when you evaluate
this data uh these neurons on this data
point
it becomes always zero
so why then why this is a problem
because we use the gradient based
training
and gradient of the constant function is
zero so
gradient descent does not work so this
is the simple explanation of 1d
parameter
setup so if we start with this red realm
and you'd apply the gradient descent
it doesn't update at all and just stay
there and
just nothing happened so
the question is then in a more general
setup
what how likely we start our
initialization
in this red realm and recall that
when applying gradient descent like
algorithm we
randomly initialize the parameters but
one thing we often forgotten is the step
zero
we need to choose a network architecture
which network architecture would be more
preferable
and what we quantify is definitely
depending on the depth
and the width the probability that you
start with your optimization in the red
realm
actually changes so
to this end we want to quantify dying
probability
so more rigorously we define some
probability space
and given the neural network
architecture then
we define the event where network become
a constant
so we want to identify how likely this
time
probability would be depending on your
network architecture
so one asymptotic result we show is the
following
given a neural network give neural
network and suppose your
network parameters are iid from
symmetric distribution
then line probability goes to one
if you fix the width and let the depth
goes to infinity
and furthermore if you fix the depth
and the width goes to infinity then this
dying probability is a zero
and this is somehow explains why in
practice the wide network is
successfully used and not a deep and
narrow network
although deep and narrow network enjoys
some quite useful
or theoretical guarantees so in simple
words
probabilistic explanation on when dying
rarely occur
simple words a deep relu network will
eventually die
in probability while a wide rail network
will not die
in probability so this is a symptotic
result
and we can go further to provide the
non-asymptotic result
and here we assume some standard
assumptions the double the weight
matrixes
are from gaussian and bij is
zero which is the common in practice
such as the key initialization or xavier
initialization
but we have somehow restrict ourselves
to the one dimensional case
due to technical difficulties but to the
end
what we can get is the lower and upper
bound
and this can be illustrated by the
following
figure here we show the dying
probability with respect to the number
of hidden layer
at different width 2 to 10.
upper and the lower dashed lines is
coming from our upper and the lower
bound
and the solid mark are our
empirical simulation obtained from one
million monte carlo simulation
and one particular thing you can see
that these two bound
are pretty accurate to capture all the
result
and in particular when the number of
hidden layer is 10
and the width is 2 we can see that dying
probability is
0.01 which is
same as what we empirically observed so
this
is accurately predict what we have
observed in practical situation
in approximating absolute value of x
okay then now how we avoid dying rail
there are multiple
choices you can avoid the dying railway
but
if you want to use the deep and narrow
network
then there are other options we propose
and why give narrow well it enjoys some
optimal density properties as proposed
by many
uh methods for example a key building
block of showing the universal
approximation theorem is multi
construct a multiplication operator and
if you look at how those
uh networks are constructed then their
fundamental level they construct the dbm
neural network
and to this end what we have proposed is
the randomized asymmetric initialization
the idea is breaking the symmetry
because
all the existing methods utilizing
symmetric distribution
actually the symmetric distribution
actually in
fundamental reason why we
often face this design red loop
especially when the number of the depths
goes large
the idea is the random selection and
initialized via specific beta
distribution
and this can be obtained theoretically
by controlling the
the expected square length of the output
of the network
then by utilizing our proposed method we
can drastically reduce the dying
probability
so here is the dying probability with
respect to the number of a hidden layer
and here is the width 2 and red
line is the one obtained by our widget
and the key initialization and also on
the initialization
are doesn't very helpful in reducing the
dying probability
and actually this also improved the
robustness of the training
here i showed the same learning task
approximating the absolute value of
x then a is the completely failure
just to become collapsed and b is the
partial collapse and c is a successful
training
and you can see that by only changing
initialization
the probability of getting a is reduced
by roughly 50 percent
and half training increased by like 20
percent
and number of success is increased by 35
and we also apply this initialization
technique for the mnist test
and five independent simulation we see
that
all the research initialized by the
randomized
symmetry initialization produces the all
good result
however just using key initialization
you can see that
you may face in some failure of the
training and some
the test accuracy is deteriorating some
cases
okay so here's the summary so i
presented some
the first convergence theory of the
physics informed the neural network
it's based on the helder regularization
method and this provides a consistency
result of the physics informed neural
network
so basically mathematically it will give
you the correct answer
if you can get a good optimizer
and next week i discuss some
optimization perspective and explain the
two machine learning phenomena coming
from training
neural net one is the philanthropy
nominal the other is the dying ray loop
and based on the theoretical
understanding we propose the new
algorithms that
improve the training of the neural
network one is the active neural net
squares as you can see it drastically
improved the training performance
and just in the for example the pin
example is a
solvable versus not solvable case
and uh for the dying railway we proposed
the randomize the symmetric
initialization so that
this allows you to explore some options
of using dm neural network in particular
cases
and here are some references and that's
what i have
prepared for today and i'm happy to take
any and questions yeah thank you okay
thank you so much it was a wonderful
talk
although it was a theoretically oriented
i was able to follow
clearly um that was amazing
amazing okay so we do have
we do have a question um
okay the first question okay by the way
do you have a
access to the chat chat box
if you move your mouse to the top of the
shared screen
then there is your option um okay
the chat chat option okay so so that you
can have access to
okay the question from lauren the first
first question is
regarding slide 19 for your assumption
number one
which is exis existence of a suitable
well-behaved interpolation function
i'm not sure i understood that correctly
is the is the status
satisfaction of such an assumption
likely to be problematic
when the data is coming not from the
actual pde
but rather from potentially noisy
experimental data
that the pde is attempting to model
yeah actually that's a that's a very
good question so
the assumption so at this moment we
don't assume any
noisiness of our uh pde data so we
somehow assume some ideal cases
where we don't have any noise
but noise can be easily incorporated
under certain tweaks so as i mentioned
here there are
assumption one can be relaxed so that
part actually
requires that you don't need to actually
exactly interpolate all the data but
there's some
uh allowance you can offer by
off by and that is determined by certain
rate dependent but as far as there's
some tolerance is satisfied then you can
allow some noisy data
uh and
[Music]
um and also in this setup we are not
actually fitting uh solution to the pde
rather than the pde data in the right
hand side
so uh in most of the cases you may know
what is your right hand side or
on the right-hand side f and g but
if the noise level is greater than
what it is imposed then
that is a good question i need to think
about a little bit more but that's a
that that's
a very good question yeah i hope that
answers your question
okay thank you thank you anja okay next
question is coming from
um sampa um he asked
even in finite element method sometimes
boundary
condition is not perfectly satisfied for
example
non-conforming meshes can we
similarly relax the boundary condition
satisfied condition to
just a converging sequence instead
uh that's that's that's very good
question yeah i think that is a possible
that is possible because the
um yeah that's very good question
okay um the next question is yeah
yeah okay um so
next question is uh from andrew
he asked for the 2d function
approximation example
of the booking function did you compare
to any classical interpolation
techniques that do not
use neural networks they should perform
fine
in this setting oh yeah sure i we we
didn't test
against other uh classical method
because the
our focus was to understand uh how we
can improve the neural network
training uh using
uh shallow neural network at the first
um
so i think the focus is a little bit
different so our goal is not
approximating to find the best
approximation tool that approximate the
2d function
rather than devised uh how we can train
the shallow neural network com uh
compared to existing
method like existing method cannot do
but i do believe that if you use some uh
orthogonal polynomial like tensor
product or some free
basis would perform uh well
for those tasks yeah that's that's also
a good question yeah
but our main focus was to okay let's
improve the neurological training
because the neuron ethical training is
not
very solid at the moment so yeah
okay um next question is from somehow
again
uh he said just curious what does the
network
architecture for the wave equation look
like for example
it's a very it's very simple network
it's a shallow
shallow network just a two layer with
and we use activation function is the
relu
power i i forgot what was the order i
think the
rail cube or fourth power of the rail
loop
yeah so it is a dense dense network yeah
okay uh next question from sophia
uh in any pin cases did you observe the
phenomenon of
double descent where a model appears to
asymptotes
but if you give it enough time and
epochs
you will observe another descent in
error
that's also a very good question i
haven't
focusing on the phenomena of the double
descent because
double decent is sort of like understood
along the way of the training procedure
so that in terms of the getting minimal
perspective
i yeah to get to the question
uh yeah i do empirically i do observe
some double decent phenomena in
training pins but as you can see in
these the
specific examples you can treat this as
a
flat of i mean double descent i mean
it's a increasing high and decrease and
also
increase decrease increase decrease you
you may think of this
as a double descent i'm not sure whether
it is also called double descent but i
do empirically observe them some double
descent
um
but if you give it enough time and
apples you will observe another
dissenting error
and that's i'm not quite sure because i
usually run
training in maximum 1 million iterations
so
but typically 10k so i'm not quite sure
on that part
yeah that um like enough
epochs okay
okay so um i don't see any more
questions from
chat room but you can only yourself and
ask a
question directly um i have a question
about the dying probability
based on the analysis there it sounds
like
it's more favorable the neural network
is a
you know wide shallow network than
deep deep narrow
network right but in practice
you know the deep narrow network is a
lot more popular than the
shallow wide network yeah so that that's
also very good question
so i haven't thought about it so this is
also irrelevant to what i did
but uh some empirical my experience is
that
if you want to express some sort of like
uh
sharp changing behavior like shock
i would recommend you go with the dim
network
because uh that is somehow more
oriented to work i would say more
efficient to represent the sharp
transition but if you want some smooth
behavior
shallow will do the good job
so and also in practical level uh
deep and narrow network uh sometimes
does not
work very well in
multiple reasons i think uh one is the
initialization
and the other is the
the number of the depth quite matter and
also the specific architecture you if
you use a resonant
or some batch normalization and some
other techniques
also comes into the play and personally
i
read a couple of papers that some mean
field approach of training neural
network that indicates that
super wide neural network can
interpolate like
almost anything but personally
when i tried i couldn't
quite get the same research and i think
the
one of the reason is that theoretical
one only says that
when time goes to infinity or certain
number of iteration
uh then you will achieve some certain
desirable error but in practical case
what i can do is just a 1k
or 1 million iteration so probably that
might be
one of the reason i might see i hope
that
answers what you ask yeah yeah
okay um i don't see any more questions
um is there any any any
any person who wants to ask directly
um uh can i can i answer a question
yeah yeah so so you you're sure that the
a
a n l s uh method is a very good tool
uh to to solve the uh fatal problem
um it must be my thought i i didn't some
i somehow didn't catch
what is that method is about how it
differs from
the traditional method can you
like briefly remind me about that method
uh active neural networks yes
oh yeah so actually i didn't explain it
uh how the how it this method can be
extended to the multi-dimensional case
because that is the will of coming soon
but the
main logic is that explicit adjustment
of the activation function
activation pattern because the
stagnation occurs when you don't change
your activation function
so that we so what gde takes a long time
is that they take a really long time to
until they change
the new activation function and then
they decay fast again
so our idea is all right then since the
changing activation function
activation pattern takes a long time for
traditional method
then why now we manually changing it
explicitly
so explicit adjustment of activation
pattern
is the key idea uh so
operationally how how do you change the
activation pattern all right so
you don't need to access you need to go
over all any
um loss function you can just
compare your uh training data
and your specific neuron and see how you
can change the activation function
locally so
uh i think this uh so this illustrates
very well so suppose this is your
current activation pattern
then what you can do is move move to the
left then this creates a new activation
function
right this creates another activation
an activation pattern i mean so this is
how we generate for 1d case
okay so how probably read your paper to
so for more detail yeah
thank you yeah yeah so this this
procedure is explained in the
public so it will be to appear on
science journal of scientific computing
so
uh yeah this is what we mean by explicit
adjustment of the activation pattern so
this
is the key part how we can efficiently
uh
get a good training result yeah that's a
very good question yeah thank you
thank you all right maybe a little bit
more on this quest
question do you have to manually find
the pattern
so i don't i don't see how clearly
i can generate the pattern the
candidate patterns right so that's also
excellent question so that's that's why
we have a
upcoming paper on the how we generalize
this because the in one d case is
left or right so that it's quite easy to
see how you can change the activation
pattern
but in the upcoming paper we have a
procedure how we can effectively
uh generate the good candidate
direction that change the activation
pattern so
it will upcoming soon so but it is some
but underlying principle is the same
there because in high dimensional case
the same mess the same
approach does not apply because there
are infinitely many direction you can
change your you can generate the
activation pattern right so
in general case we have a way to do that
and more efficient way
so that that's somehow i slipped into
those two results in here and here
and those results will be available soon
uh
probably and at the end of this month
yeah that's very good question thank you
okay
um is there any other questions yeah
yeah i have a question
okay uh hi junior this is fun
and actually i have a first i have a
question about that wave equation
uh i mean um have you ever tried like
three features
i'm very interested in that is there any
connection between the three features
and the activation patterns because
actually
fur features can do the same thing but
i'm i'm i'm wondering if
the less activation patterns can explain
this phenomena
that's interesting question i haven't
tried how
this free air feature uh can be
somehow applied actually i'm not sure
whether you remember this example
actually i borrowed this example from
one of your
paper i think yeah i'm very friendly
yeah actually
a hard time that yeah actually
i haven't thought about in that
direction but uh i think
it must be related to activation pattern
i think so that by applying the free
transformation feature transformation
somehow
your input is somehow easily
uh somehow become easy format that can
be
easily uh
easily change their activation pattern
in some sense
and it should be the reason that we give
us a better result that's my just a
high level intuition yeah i didn't know
the detailed uh
uh comment on on the part of this
but that's a good question yeah i think
that's um regarding to my second
question
so are you interested in that uh uh are
familiar with some theoretical
our approximation theory of like
diplomats
uh yes i i did the one work on the
typical net approximation i think this
is
relevant to the active neutral necessary
right
uh yeah yeah so if this is the case are
you familiar
so are you interested in like diplomats
with some physical
basic physically informed laws
oh yeah sure yeah okay
okay thank you so much that's all yeah
but i yeah i haven't tried the training
deep on that but uh
yeah yeah thank you okay it's a really
nice presentation
thank you so much okay next question
from us
from chat room um can the pluto
the phenomenon be addressed with a
adaptive learning
rate or gradient based uh annealing
methods if so how do these methods
compare with the performance of the
am ls algorithm
um adaptable learning rate and
gradient-based analytic method
um
i'm not quite sure how this adaptive
learning rate
and gradient based on knowledge method
uh
will
i think we follow the similar principle
that you just mentioned
in our upcoming paper in addressing the
multi-dimensional case because we also
utilizing the gradient information
that suitably uh changed uh effectively
change the
activation pattern so i think what you
are asking is really
uh highly connected to our upcoming
paper for uh
this generalization of active neuron
this square
so uh but i
i didn't okay then i can see so
one great feature of our on this square
is we
actually solve for apply the least
square
part for getting coefficient to c
so let me see
so here so once the internal weights are
fixed
then coefficient part can be solved by
the list of squares
and one of our scheme is uh asking
us to find the what is the solution
the the neuron that leads to the
smallest
error decay and we have a specific
algorithm and theorem
that can this part can be done very
efficiently so i think that is the one
of the key difference
and the performance wise um
i cannot say too much because i haven't
compared it with the adaptive learning
rate or gradient-based
analytic method so if you are mentioning
adaptive learning rate is the
i'm not quite sure what exactly
adaptable learning rate but
if it is meant to be some scheduled
learning rate
or some other uh learning rate
uh configuration we haven't really
tested so we just
fixed the adam to be a default manner
or in some cases though we somehow find
training the learning rate but constant
learning rate so
i hope that answers questions and i'd
like to know more about gradient
based announcing method if there exists
some
packages i can run it to compare they
will be nice
okay all right great
um any other questions i guess it's time
to wrap up
but please do not
do not reluctant to ask questions if you
have
no okay well let's thank yon zhang
for the great talk um i really enjoyed
it
and um yeah and
well actually there is one more question
from okay cloud
uh sarah i think a paris uh
party adapters that carries i had a
wonderful paper on gradient-based
annealing methods to address some
learning issues of pins okay
yeah great great comment okay thank you
let's thank the professor uh shin
again for the great talk and um
i guess we have a great expectation for
the
upcoming paper uh you you have mentioned
several times
okay we you make sure um
double check on it and okay thank you
thank you uh okay thank you in person
comfort the seminar then we could
actually clap for you but
virtual thank you thank you so much for
having me today
i really enjoyed the discussion with the
audiences
and uh really enjoyed wonderful
wonderful so i i hope that um
this can be a you know the beginning of
the future collaboration i hope that you
can be connected with
several people in lawrence livermore and
as well as
a you know the external people who
joined this seminar
okay with that let's let's end
um